America's homelessness crisis continues
to be an utter catastrophe once vibrant
cities Across the Nation have turned
into open air drug wastelands and the
situation only seems to get worse the
time for change has never been more
urgent and former president Donald Trump
has a simple solution when I'm back in
the white house we will use every tool
lever and authority to get the homeless
off our streets and for those who are
severely mentally ill and deeply
Disturbed we will bring them back to
mental institutions where they belong
with the goal of reintegrating them back
into society once they are well enough
to manage Trump's plan to bring back
mental institutions might not be that
radical Boston is planning for a 35 acre
Island facility to combat homelessness
addiction and mental health Greg yes are
they stealing the island idea yes yes
but the the sad thing is if they do this
how will MSNBC survive they're going to
lose all their anchor and almost all
their viewers we live in an era sadly
where the best thing you could do for
the mentally ill is seen as a violation
of their rights what you're talking
about is trying to treat people who
can't fend for themselves but for some
reason that has been turned into an
grieved group that deserves protection
from something that will save their life
it's actually a subversion of human
compassion in order to protect them let
them suffer and die because you need to
preserve them as a marginalized group of
course institutionalization makes it
exists it was there before the opposite
of
institutionalization is leaving them in
cities full of things no mentally ill
person could handle the Relentless
stimulus of every even for a sane person
is nuts the stressful conditions the you
know the loud noises the the crowds
these are things that are torture worthy
of a black op site for somebody who is
homeless and mentally ill this is why
sanitariums were often in the rural
Countryside you need to remove the
vulnerable from the things that torture
them but then again that's a violation
of their rights you can't take them out
and do that but therefore the left has
no solution because you have to let the
mentally ill person make the decision
for themselves and they can't do that so
they're left festering and dying on the
streets and now that Trump speaks the
truth the left is going to have to
Galvanize against it like they did with
the wall because no matter if it's right
if it comes from trump it has to be
wrong because you can't side with them
even though you're seeing yourself the
destruction of humanity before your eyes
there a lot of liberals in New York City
they walk by these people they walk by
them every day and they know these
people need help but they can't they
they would much rather be against Trump
than stretch out their hand and get that
person into a
hospital and why don't we take all the
money we're spending on migrant Dana and
then build beautiful mental institutions
for our people hey I mean I listen I
love that president Trump is talking
about it his campaign videos are are
pretty interesting if you can go back
and look the the ideas that he has on
policies people think that he is just
has grievances about the past he has
those yes but he also has been doing a
lot of these policy videos we also have
grievances about the homeless I have
grievances I am so tired of walking by
them I mean and thank goodness in a this
is a weird thing to say but with the
drugs of choice today these people are
like sedated on the sidewalk imagine if
they were violent yeah well the crack
you couldn't walk by them and then this
idea would be something that like KLA
Harris would come up with and people
would think it was great I think that
President Biden is late to this one of
the things I love to do is if I'm out
and about getting a chance to ask people
that live other places what's the
biggest problem in your community that
you're trying to solve and I have been
shocked that in the smallest towns in
America in Colorado homelessness is
their problem so this is not just a
liberal City problem this is happening
all across America and someone has to
get a handle on it a huge problem that
President Trump would have if he tried
this one would be all the legal issues
ETC but there's not enough skilled staff
and there's not enough people wanting to
go into that field there's not enough
money to pay them they to pay them like
a salary in which you would say I really
want to do this kind of work it's very
very difficult but it is it would be the
compassionate thing to do if we can just
get past all of that we have to have
some solutions because it was just like
a NeverEnding circling of the drain here
right because it's easier to just give
them prescription drug drugs that zone
them out than to actually care for them
and help them 24/7 now that you know
that Trump's for insane asylums are you
against
it so this idea is something that's
actually popular in a lot of liberal
policy circles not necessarily insane
asylums because we do know that these
huge large scale um psychiatric
facilities were shut down in the mid
1900s because of inhumane treatment
right the people were essentially just
being put in padded rooms and we getting
things like labotomy and not actually
being C ured of what they have so if you
can find a solution where you have good
staff and you have doctors that are
going to help people and not just keep
them in a proverbial cage there are a
lot of people that are for that there's
also a difference between creating a
community which is what the Boston plan
is and just putting up these mental
facilities and I think that you could
find really good Common Ground then
between Trump's plan which by the way he
also had going into Co this is something
from his administration but then we were
overtaken um by the virus and they
didn't get to move forward with it but
if you have it as a place where people
can go and they can become employed they
can have affordable housing and they can
have a chance to get the kind of mental
treatment uh mental health treatment
that they need I think you can make
progress a big step towards that though
there are caps um on how much Medicaid
funding that these facilities can get
it's been a big push especially from the
left to get those caps either raised or
just eliminated all together so that you
can increase the size and the number of
people you can treat I would be for that
but are you saying inv volunt
I'm Pro involuntary I I get that um you
don't have to say some people no I know
that on the show I don't feel much
pressure to say what the rest of you are
saying no I think that when you look at
a case you should J well I don't which
is how I keep my job um like Jordan
Neely right is the perfect example where
I think everyone would agree that that
was a good candidate for involuntary
commitment the point is that there have
to be a multitude of options there are
some people who are dangerous and
violent and there are other people
people who you could talk to who would
go voluntarily yeah but they never do I
I don't know if they have the options I
understand this is a new federal program
which is different than the cities right
but I actually don't trust that this
would be carried out in a way that
actually respected people's civil rights
given what we've seen with the
Department of Justice and how they
Define what they think is a mental
illness and that kind of thing they do
this with the Second Amendment with red
flag laws I think there's a lot of
things there the issue with the
homelessness problem and and why it's
gotten worse and not better with the
influx of Medicaid money and the influx
of money from States like California to
the tune of billions and billions of
dollars is government corruption they
have an incentive when they're in charge
to keep people homeless because they get
paid we have a friend who worked in in a
DC homeless shelter as an employee and
he was making less money than people
were getting by living on the street
because of all the benefits that they
were receiving we have made it easy in
this country to live on the street if
you want to make it so people make
decisions about getting off the streets
getting clean you have to put them in
jail consequences for actions and you
have to take away their ability to be
incentivized to benefit and of course
you have to take away all these
incentives and structures that the
governments local and federal have put
in place to make this problem continue
rather than go away solving this problem
doesn't help anybody who's benefiting
from it all right good conversation
everybody really thoughtful happy this
like I love the idea in concept I just
don't trust it in all right well I'll
strike a night's balance my
Administration will handle it hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else